We are on problem number 11.
I wrote out that chart,
although you
probably can't read it.
So they say, according to the
table above, car engine oil
with a rating of 5w flows how
many times as fast as a car
engine oil with a
rating of 20w?
So how much faster
is 5w versus 20w?
So let's read the chart.
It says 10w is half
as fast as 5w.
So 5w is twice as fast as 10w.
So 5w is 2 times 10w.
Then they tell us that 15w
is half as fast as 10w.
So 10w is double the
speed of 15w.
Actually, let's do
it that way.
10w is double the speed
of 15w, right?
And then 15w is double
the speed of 20w.
So you have two doublings.
So 10w is going to be 4 times as
fast. It's 2 times as fast
as this, which is 2 times
as fast as this.
So 10w is 4 times
faster than 20w.
So 10w is 4 times 20w.
And 5w is twice 10w.
So 5w is going to
be 8 times 20w.
And really, the most confusing
thing about this is the fact
that these labels for these
ratings involve numbers that
aren't proportional to actually
how much faster they
are than each other.
You could actually change this
to x, y, z, and then it might
be a little bit easier.
But that's all there is to it.
This is twice as fast
as this, which is
twice as fast as this.
And if you were at 5w up here,
so 5w is twice as fast as
this, which is twice as fast
as this, which is twice as
fast as that.
So you're doubling three times,
so it's 8 times as
fast. And that's choice C.
Next problem.
Let me draw that.
We have a line like that.
Straight line at the bottom.
Then we have a line.
Looks something like that.
And this is P, A, Q, B, R.
This is line m.
This is line l.
Figure not drawn to the scale.
Sure.
In the figure above, points
P, A, and B are equally
spaced on line l.
Equally spaced.
So that means that the distance
from P to A is equal
to the distance from A to B.
They're equally spaced.
That's good to know.
And points P, Q, and R are
equally spaced on line m.
OK.
So P, Q, and R are
equally spaced.
It didn't look like it
the way I drew it.
But so this is equal to this.
If PB is equal to 4-- so that
entire thing is equal to 4.
So we immediately know
that this is 2
and this is 2, right?
Because they're equally
spaced.
PR is equal to 6.
So this entire thing
is equal to 6.
So we know that this
is 3 and this is 3.
And AQ is 4.
What is the perimeter of
quadrilateral QABR?
Let's see, where is Q?
QABR.
So we know this side.
We know this side.
We just have to figure
out this side.
And I'll tell you right now
that this is going to be a
similar triangle problem,
I believe.
Because these triangles are
going to be proportional to
each other.
How do I know that?
I'm going to draw two
triangles for you.
You have this big triangle,
and then you have
this smaller triangle.
And the big triangle is similar
to the smaller triangle.
And how do I know that?
Well, they share
an angle here.
and we know that the bigger
triangle, two of its sides are
just double the sides of
the other two angles.
Or-- I'm sorry.
We know that, for example, this
side on the big triangle
is double this side on the
small triangle, right?
Similar.
We know this big side on the
big triangle is double this
side on the small triangle.
So two sides are proportional
to each other.
We have one common angle.
We know that this is
a similar triangle.
So we know that this side is
going to be double this side.
So this side is going to be 8.
And you could have probably
guessed that even if you
didn't want to prove that
they're similar triangles.
So this is 8.
The perimeter that we had to
figure out to begin with--
this is the quadrilateral
right here.
It's going to be 8 plus
3 plus 4 plus 2.
And what is that?
That's 8 plus-- 17.
Right?
6, 9, right.
17.
And that is choice E.
Next problem.
Problem 13.
OK.
13 and 14 refer to
these functions.
So g of n is equal to
n squared plus n.
h of n is equal to n
squared minus n.
So the first problem.
They want to know what g
of 5 minus h of 4 is.
So g of 5.
Let's stick in 5 into g.
So you get 5 squared plus 5.
I just replace 5 where n is.
And then we're going
to subtract h of n.
So what's h of n?
Oh, sorry, h of 4.
It looked like an n.
And h of 4.
So h of 4 is 4 squared
minus 4.
And so let's simplify this.
That's 25 plus 5 minus
16 plus 4.
So that's what?
30 minus 16 plus 4.
30 minus 16 is 14, plus
4, so it's 18.
So that is choice D.
All right.
Problem 14 also applies
to this.
So I'll do it right here.
Which of the following is
equivalent to h of m plus 1?
So we essentially just,
everywhere we see an n here,
we put an m plus 1.
So h of m plus 1 is equal to--
we see an n, so we put an m
plus 1 there.
m plus 1 squared minus-- instead
of an n-- m plus 1.
Multiply that out.
You get m squared plus 2m plus
1, and then minus m minus 1.
Let's see.
So this 1 and this
1 cancel out.
And then 2m minus m.
So you're left with
m squared minus m.
So h of m plus 1 is equal
to m squared minus m.
But isn't that the same
thing as h of m?
Reminds me of that store.
That's H&M, not h of m, although
that would be a fun
name for a store as well.
h of m.
Well, what's h of m?
You put an m where
you see an n.
So that also equals
m squared minus m.
So the answer is h of m.
And let me now look
at the choices.
And that is not there.
So I have made a mistake.
m squared plus 1.
They're saying, which of the
following is equal to h of m--
let me clear things.
OK.
So they say, which of the
following is equivalent to h
of m plus 1?
And that is equal to
h of m, right?
Right.
That is equal to m plus 1
squared minus m plus 1.
That's m squared plus 2m plus
1, minus m, minus 1.
So that's m squared-- plus m.
Oh, sorry.
Plus m.
m squared plus m.
And then this cancels out.
So h of m plus 1 is equal
to m squared plus m.
Right?
And what's m squared plus m?
Well, that's the same
thing as g of m.
Because take g of n, or take
g of m and that's also m
squared plus m.
So that is choice A.
Before I cleared it, my mistake
was when I did 2m
minus m, I got, for some silly
reason, minus m instead of
positive m.
Should be a positive m.
That was my mistake.
I'll see you in the next video.